good morning belief nation today's
messages have more courage over to you
Tai Lopez
increase your courage harden up a little
bit take a cold shower don't always take
a warm shower acclimate your mind and
your body to doing things that are
harder you know one of my friends who's
one of the most successful people in the
young startup but made a billion dollar
valuation on company of five years
whenever we're talking about new ideas
we're gonna do next if I say oh that's
gonna be easy why don't we do that he
says time
there's no money in what's easy focus on
these intangibles you know the ability
to have a ton of courage a lot of people
think that you have to be your daredevil
to be a successful entrepreneur that you
need to quit your job and mortgage your
house to the max and go all-in and burn
all your boats and bridges and just
commit yourself 100% to being an
entrepreneur and that's simply not the
case you don't need to be a massive
risk-taker and they're able to be
successful in business and most I would
say of them of the most successful ones
aren't that kind of personality but at
the same time you have to have some
courage you have to have the willingness
to be a little bit uncomfortable and
stretch outside your comfort zone and I
think that's the recipe not just for
business success but but success and
Happiness as a human being if you are
doing the same thing over and over again
every single day you're gonna get bored
it's tiring people need to feel like
they're growing personally and whether
that's picking up a new language
learning how to salsa dance trying a new
business mustering the courage to ask
somebody to go out with you or to marry
you
all of these things all of the great
moments in your life happen when you
have the courage to step outside your
comfort zone and do something a little
bit greater than you were before and I
encourage people to think about what can
you do in your business and your in your
life to constantly stretch yourself to
constantly grow to have a circle of
people who push you to be more
courageous and
you feel like you can accomplish your
big dream and do something bigger and
better than what you are right now so
you don't need to be a daredevil but you
have to have some courage and I
encourage you to find ways today to step
outside your comfort zone and do
something more courageous
so my question that they for you today
is what are you going to do today that
pushes you to be a little bit more
courageous what action are you gonna
take leave it in the comments below and
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso